[Musica]
offre ogni giorno non lo devono dire
rete lasciato un biglietto
cosa c'è scritto se lo slime arcobaleno
vorrei creare tutti gli ingredienti
dovrai trovare ps mai toccare la coda
dell'unicorno bene devo cercare di
ingredienti arcobaleno allora ecco
[Musica]
che cosa sta facendo ha messo le ciotole
e la spatola
scappato vediamo che cosa ha lasciato
tre ciotole trono perché tre forse dovrò
fare tre slime guarda c'è un altro
biglietto
ti piacciono gli unicorni sì o no devo
mettere una ics
sì certo che mi piacciono gli unicorni
sì allora guarda qua in questo mondo
niente è come sembra
chi sei tu schizzi sono la tua fata
madrina hanno rapito mio fratello
charlie puoi usare la bacchetta magica
per riportarlo ad amia
non troveremo conosco l'agente segreto
più famoso del mondo nessuno verrà a
salvarti ragazzino fidati nell'ordine
c'è ancora tempo per salvare charlie ma
prima ti dovrai convincere di potercela
fare
cristina d'avena è la fata madrina ajax
è l'imperatore max adoro d'oro d'oro
liberate la bestia immobile
dal 31 dicembre al cinema ma sembra
fantastico ci sono anche gli unicorni
andrò sicuramente a vederlo andrete
anche voi mi raccomando andate nel box
informazioni qui sotto per vedere il
trailer completo del film playmobil ma
ora dobbiamo trovare gli ingredienti
slime arcobaleno vediamo dove potrebbero
essere se qualcosa ecco a dietro non c'è
niente potrà però essere magari sopra il
letto
vediamo anche se non penso che l'unico
non riesca salire la sopra è un po
sizione nulla argentata glitterata e
ricevi un altra viola glitterata ora
glitterata magari troppo tutti gli
ingredienti qui sarebbe fantastico e
rosa liberata se ci sa fare lo slime
arcobaleno no vabbè mi manca la
soluzione per lenti e il bicarbonato
[Musica]
ma che sta facendo
la soluzione per lenti
devo stare attenta a non parlare troppo
a voce alta perchè si spaventa molto
facilmente questo unicorno ha lasciato
la soluzione per lenti allora prendo
queste colle e le porte giu e poi manca
solo il bicarbonato fantastico alla
soluzione per lenti in mano o il
bicarbonato che cos'è devo stare attenta
perché se spaventa molto facilmente
grazie a mano senza
[Musica]
che succede
capii verdi rosa viola
devo andare a mare nello specchio
[Musica]
trasformata in una sorta di unicorno o
fatina ecco perché c'era scritto di non
toccare la coda l'unicorno a che stupida
e adesso come faccio a tornare normale
forse devo nuovamente toccare la coda
l'unicorno anche se non so dove sia
scappa sempre
oppure devo completare lo stai
marcobaleno proviamo a completare lo
slime vediamo se riesco a tornare
normale andiamo sbrighiamoci allora
tonino lasciato il bicarbonato per
fortuna o se non devo andare a cercarlo
questi capelli colorati mi danno
fastidio allora ci sono 38 le ma quattro
colori
forse devo unire due colori assieme
vediamo sicuramente di abusare rosa
perché anche nei miei capelli quindi
mettiamolo qua
ecco fatto bellissima rosa con i pixel e
ora mettiamo un po di viola che ho anche
nei capelli
e ora veniamo oro e argento
nell'ultimo assalto la bellissimo
corretta come brilla e ora mentre faccio
lo slime mi sento più una fata che un
unicorno proprio come la fata del film e
ora l'argento allora mettiamo subito la
soluzione per lenti in tutte e tre le
ciotole e poi andremo mescolare ogni
rally slime faremo proprio un bellissimo
effetto arcobaleno sono sicuro che non
ricorrono non rimarrà deluso
che bello ora il recento che si uniscono
bellissimi
ora il bicarbonato che potrebbe sembrare
tipo la polvere magica di fatah katana
tra l'altro la voce della fata e proprio
di cristina d'avena wow è bellissimo
brilla tantissimo ecco fatto questo è
pronto oro e argento bellissimo e ancora
un pochino pizzi colto wow
adoro questo colore questi invece quello
viola e bellissimo che questo colore e
questo e quello rosa questo è il mio
preferito è bellissimo tra l'altro
sembra propria rosa dei miei capelli
guardate o no no no no no no
pigliate capelli per fortuna poi tornerò
con i capelli normali
spero che lo slang scomparirà i nostri
tre slam sono pronti
e giunto il momento di fare l'arcobaleno
attacchiamo le casi mette un po di oro
da una parte e un po dall'altra ecco qua
ora facciamo un bel offrirle che belli
colori sono stupendi e una fatta di
arcobaleno o argentato dorato un po
fatato guardate che bello e stupendo mi
piace un sacco ma io ho completato lo
slime perché non sono tornata normale
che cos'altro devo fare chi è
tutto il giorno ciao un giorno grazie ma
senti io volevo dirti che mi sono
trasformato in un'icona come temo ho
fatto lo slime ho fatto lo slime
arcobaleno come richiesto vuoi farmi
tornare normale ti prego
[Musica]
tornato normale lo slime ancora qua per
fortuna ho di nuovo i miei capelli e i
miei vestiti
vediamo che cosa ha lasciato l'unicorno
[Musica]
playmobil the movie con le voci di j ax
e cristina d'avena dal 31 dicembre
alzino ma non vedo l'ora di vederlo
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete altri
video slime unicorno xi o unicorni
ricorda che il film playmobil the movie
e al cinema dal 31 dicembre
io non vedo l'ora di vederlo e voi e ora
vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao
[Musica]